die nachrichten des tages heute nichts
guten abend schön dass sie dabei sind
wie auch norbert lehmann für den sport
von schiller familie corona beschäftigt
uns weiter
höchste wert seit mai die bundesweite
sieben tage incidents erreicht zum
ersten mal wieder die 100er marke
erdogan droht mit rauswurf der türkische
präsident bezeichnet 10 botschafter
darunter auch den deutschen als
unerwünschte personen
und auftakt in den alpinen schieben die
amerikanerin michaela chiffren gewinnt
den riesenslalom auf dem gletscher in
sölden
ist es wirklich ratsam in zeiten
steigender infektionszahlen den corona
ausnahmezustand auslaufen zu lassen
die diskussion um das ende der
sogenannten epidemischen lage von
nationaler tragweite geht weiter
gesundheitsminister sparen will ja dass
ende november damit schluss ist betont
aber jetzt dass das nicht als
aufforderung zur nachlässigkeit
verstanden werden soll heiko pisa hat
mehr
mit dem mobilen im zelt dorthin wo die
leute sind mitten in stuttgart gibt es
den schutz gegen das corona virus ganz
spontan und der andrang ist groß
gesundheitsminister sparen betont selbst
wenn der korona ausnahmezustand bald
nicht mehr gelten sollte wird das nicht
das ende der einschränkungen seien nach
allem was ich weiß berät die ampel auch
genau darüber eben eine
bundesgesetzliche grundlage zu schaffen
für 3g für masken in bus und bahn die
inzidenz steigt heute zum ersten mal
seit mai wieder auf 100 der spd
gesundheitsexperte lauterbach ist jetzt
der falsche zeitpunkt für die diskussion
wir haben jetzt die besonders schwierige
lage dass wir möglicherweise die regeln
noch verschärfen müssen obwohl wir die
epidemische lage für beendet erklären
das kann keiner verstehen vor allem im
süden deutschlands steigt die inzidenz
wieder an in thüringen liegt sie sogar
bei über 200 und es fällt auf in fast
allen dieser länder liegt die impfquote
unter dem bundesschnitt die kassen herr
zu sagen deshalb man kann nicht mehr
ganz deutschland über einen kamm scheren
nehmen sie auch in schleswig holstein
als die sieben tage ins events bei rund
18 in meiningen in thüringen bei 220 da
muss man natürlich also faktor 10 und da
muss natürlich sagen das müssen dann
auch unterschiedliche maßnahmen
unterschiedlichen bundesländern
ergriffen werden dabei aber bitte die
intensivstationen nicht aus den augen
verlieren warnen die mitarbeitenden dort
wir haben innerhalb eines jahres
ungefähr 5000 intensivbetten die wir
nicht mehr betreiben können aufgrund des
pflege mangels der unterschied führt
jetzt dazu dass wir heute unter 1000
freie betten für beatmungspatienten
haben bei einem sind sich alle einig
impfen und die regeln schützen vor hohen
instanzen und vor weiteren
einschränkungen in den kommenden
wintermonaten
ein anderes corona modell verfolgen die
briten seit juli gibt es dort nahezu
keine corona beschränkungen mehr im
glauben mit einer impfrate von knapp 80
prozent bald die so genannte
herdenimmunität zu erreichen doch die
zahlen nehmen wieder zu pro tag 50.000
neue infektionen immer mehr
klinikpatienten
experten fordern jetzt es brauche
dringend wieder beschränkungen jasin
herlein
es ist das kapital von dem der
premierminister noch heute zehrt das
frühe erfolgreiche impfprogramm hat die
briten so manchen fehler der regierung
beim umgang mit corona vergessen lassen
dennoch steigen die infektionszahlen
[Musik]
ja wir beobachten hohe werte doch sie
sind im rahmen dessen was wir in unserem
plan für den herbst und im winter
erwartet haben das wichtige ist dass die
leute sich an die empfehlungen halten
wie zb das tragen von masken in
geschlossenen räumen und im öffentlichen
nahverkehr doch das ist nicht pflicht
sondern eben nur empfohlen und immer
weniger briten tunis zahlreiche
wissenschaftler äußern sich inzwischen
beunruhigt
einzig und allein auf die impfstoffe
verlassen um die dinge diesen winter
unter kontrolle zu halten riskieren wir
in ernste schwierigkeiten zu geraten
neben masten könnten mehr home office
und ein impfpass für großveranstaltungen
jetzt abhilfe schaffen sagen die
experten dazu kommt dass das im programm
zuletzt ins stocken geraten ist längst
ist das vereinigte königreich nicht mehr
spitzenreiter in europa für die unter
16-jährigen gibt es impfung erst seit
einem monat bei der verabreichung der
dritten auffrischimpfung für ältere fakt
ist
auch die krankenhaus einlieferungen
steigend zuletzt woche für woche um über
zehn prozent die regierung johnson läuft
gefahr wie so oft in der pandemie wieder
zu spät zu handeln
wie geht es weiter in der cdu im größten
landesverband in nordrhein westfalen hat
die personelle erneuerung heute begonnen
der 46 jährige hendrik wüst wurde zum
landesparteichef gewählt als nachfolger
von armin laschet der hat er ja schon
vor der bundestagswahl angekündigt dass
er auch im fall einer niederlage seine
ämter in nrw ab gibt thomas münten über
den versuch eines neuanfangs
erleichterung als nrw-verkehrsminister
hendrik wüst heute nachmittag souverän
parteivorsitzender des größten
cdu-landesverbandes wird danach haben
sie sich gesehnt die fast 700
delegierten die nach bielefeld gekommen
sind der 46 jährige machte schon in
seiner bewerbungsrede klar angriffe aus
den eigenen reihen nimmt er anders als
sein vorgänger
leute wir haben die bundestagswahl
verloren und so wie es aussieht haben
wir auch die regierungsbeteiligung
verloren wir dürfen aber nicht noch
anstand mitnehmen und haltung verlieren
liebe freundinnen und freunde in der
union muss wieder gelten haltung stadt
spaltung
haben laschet war zuvor mit
fünfminütigen standing ovations
verabschiedet worden heute ganz
entspannt könnte er sich setzte in
richtung friedrich merz und norbert
röttgen beide im saal
wenn ich jetzt lese wieder manche als
kandidatin des bundes vorsitzes sicht
präsentieren und so ist die größte krise
der cdu seit 1945 oder ähnliches naja
das inspiriert überhaupt kein wähler
wieder cdu zu wählen all das war
wirklich ja unsinn
einigkeit will die zivilen demonstrieren
und einen generationswechsel
doch im achtköpfigen parteivorstand
sitzen nur drei neue gesichter hendrik
wüst will am mittwoch im landtag auch
zum ministerpräsidenten gewählt werden
die nächste herausforderung die
regierungskoalition hat nur eine stimme
mehrheit
die bundeskanzlerin hofft dass bei der
neuaufstellung ihrer partei mehr frauen
zum zug kommen nur männer das passt
nicht mehr in die zeit sagte merkel der
süddeutschen zeitung in ihrem ersten
interview nach der bundestagswahl und
sie fordert frauen auf sich aktiv um
parteiämter zu bewerben es müsse weiter
daran gearbeitet werden dass sich frauen
insgesamt mehr zutrauen
nach brandenburg dort kommen seit wochen
wieder mehr flüchtende an seit august
gab es nach angaben der behörden rund
4500 illegale übertritte an der polnisch
deutschen grenze
neonazis wollen jetzt mit einer so
genannten bürgerwehr stimmung gegen
migranten machen das wiederum wollen
andere brandenburger und
brandenburgerinnen nicht hinnehmen sagte
stermann und jan meyer berichten über
die brücke von google kommen nur wenige
flüchtlinge dennoch wächst die sorge in
der grenzstadt denn seit august hat sich
die zahl der an der grenze aufgegriffen
menschen verzehnfacht man kann sich auf
einen
erlebe für das viele ausländer hier
rüber kommen tag und nach und ich habe
nichts dagegen für der ausländer aber es
nimmt über daran die stimmung ist
aufgeheizt in einer region in der die
afg bei der bundestagswahl jede vierte
stimme holte eine mahnwache erinnert
daran wie schnell hass in gewalt
umschlagen kann unvergessen wie 1999
rechtsextremisten in google den
algerischen asylbewerber oma bin zu tode
hetzen für dieses wochenende haben
neonazis dazu aufgerufen flüchtlinge an
der grenze zu stoppen bin hier um zu
zeigen dass ich
mich das überhaupt nicht einverstanden
bin dass leute von außerhalb her komme
und hier selbst an unsere grenze zu
schützen unterdessen hat die
bundespolizei acht zusätzliche
hundertschaften an die grenze verlegt um
flüchtlinge aufzugreifen provinz
bürgermeister fordert darüber hinaus die
kontrollen an den übergängen wieder
aufzunehmen
corona jetzt die flüchtlinge das sind
alles dinge die auf die menschen hier
einprasseln und das verunsichert
natürlich die unsichere lage an der
grenze ist am mittwoch einziges thema
einer sondersitzung des landtages in
potsdam beantragt hat sie die fraktion
der afd
ein streit zwischen der türkei und
anderen ländern eskaliert gerade es geht
um den inhaftierten menschenrechtler aus
man kavala präsident erdogan will
mehrere botschafter auch den deutschen
zu unerwünschten personen erklären
lassen sie hatten in einem brief die
freilassung covers gefordert der
unternehmer und kultur mit zehn sitzt
seit vier jahren in haft zunächst war
ihm vorgeworfen worden er habe die
regierungskritischen proteste
organisiert später hieß es kavala sei am
putschversuch 2016 gegen präsident
erdogan beteiligt gewesen
fragen wir luckwald in istanbul das ist
doch ein gewagter schritt wenn der
türkische präsident jetzt tatsächlich
die botschafter seiner wichtigsten nato
verbündeten ausweist warum macht er das
ja es ist vielleicht auch ein hinweis
auf eine verzweifelte lage erdogan steht
innenpolitisch unter sehr hohem druck es
läuft einfach nicht rund und das schon
seit geraumer zeit praktisch seit vor
zwei jahren die großen städte an die
opposition gegangen sind wären jetzt
wahlen käme seine partei nicht mal mehr
auf 30 prozent und in diesem jahr
verzweifelten schritt sucht er
möglicherweise sein heil wir das in der
vergangenheit schon öfter gemacht hat
nämlich eine außenpolitische krise
herbeireden und dann wieder als starker
verteidiger der großen türkischen nation
auftreten der grund warum es nicht rund
läuft ist aber hausgemacht die
wirtschaft läuft nicht die soziale not
wächst hohe inflation hohe
arbeitslosigkeit kursverfall der
türkischen lira die erdogan selber immer
wieder
beschleunigt dadurch dass er eingreift
in die politik der zentralbank und ja
jetzt sucht er offenbar sein heiligen
aussenpolitischen krisen und hofft damit
die reihen zu schließen und wieder die
anhänger zu mobilisieren wie er das in
der vergangenheit schon gemacht hat ihm
sitzt allerdings auch ein ultra rechter
ultranationalistische koalitionspartner
im nacken aber ob diese rechnung aufgeht
ist doch sehr fraglich man wird sehen
vor allen dingen wie die märkte am
montag reagieren noch ist kein
botschafter ausgereist aber es könnte
eine spirale in gang setzen die erde
wandern auch nur noch schwer
kontrollieren kann dankeschön aus
istanbul nach
ungarn das welt im nächsten frühjahr ein
neues parlament heute zum
wahlkampfauftakt am nationalfeiertag
wurde schon
es wird spannend die opposition wittert
ihre chance hat sich zusammengetan und
einen gemeinsamen kandidaten aufgestellt
peter markise doch auf der anderen seite
steht viktor orban seit 2010 sitzt er
als ministerpräsident fest im sattel
britta hilpert
am nationalfeiertag zeigt sich ungarn
gespalten gleich zwei massendemos gab es
aber nur eine zeigte das nationale
fernsehen die des regierungschefs viktor
orban vergleicht sich mit dem
volksaufstand von 56 es wehe die bresche
wirft doktrin durch europa heute wollten
europäische chefs über ungarn hinweg
entscheiden er poltert gegen die eu
oppositionelle migranten und
minderheiten
ungarn wird das erste land in europa
sein dass die erzwungene lesben und
schwulen propaganda an schulen stoppt
dafür erntet er den stärksten beifall
er ist dass sich der zweiten demo hinter
peter martin versammeln sich mehrere
sehr unterschiedliche parteien von links
bis extrem rechts sie ein tier gegner
die korrupte regierung von viktor orban
und ärger oder schlechtes korhonen
management hunderte millionen euro gibt
dafür überflüssige art messgeräte wir
werden die verantwortlichen zur
rechenschaft ziehen verspricht er und
auch dass der rechtsstaat unabhängig von
der macht sein muss saubere politik
und sicheres einkommen sind die themen
der nächsten wahl meint die politologen
die lage ist sehr sportlich sehr eng so
eng weiß seit langem nicht mehr die wahl
wird gewinnen wer die unsicheren mir
anspricht es sind noch sechs monate bis
zur abstimmung dass der wahlkampf schon
jetzt beginnt zeigt wie verbissen er
wird
auf ruhe in den sozialen medien autoren
und autorinnen die ihre auftritte
absagen die frankfurter buchmesse ist
dieses jahr geprägt von der debatte über
die präsenz rechter verlage sie ist aber
auch geprägt von der großen freude dass
es alles rund ums lesen endlich wieder
live und leibhaftig gibt wenn auch mit
einschränkungen 3g ist pflicht
eingelassen werden pro tag nur 25.000
menschen hätten klinge
signierstunde hinter glas an manchen
ständen warteschlangen damit es kein
gedränge vor den büchern gibt die
begeisterung über die reale buchmesse
ist trotzdem groß wir sind die
vergangenen jahre immer hier gewesen und
freuen uns sehr dass wir wieder dabei
sein können auch in live und in echt
einiges ist in diesem jahr anders
breitere gänge weniger besucher ein
highlight für viele sind persönliche
begegnungen wie zum beispiel mit der
bekannten krimi autorin nele neuhaus sie
stellt ihr neues buch vor und möchte
trotz der aktuellen diskussion um rechte
verlage auf der messe präsent sein die
vielfalt hat immer auch irgendwelche
grenzen und ecken und ränder und das
muss man so akzeptieren aber am besten
akzeptiert man indem man ignoriert und
einfach wirklich dieses buch fest
feierte wegen dieses standes eines
rechten verlags sagte zum beispiel die
autorin yasmina kuhnke ihren besuch auf
der buchmesse ab andere folgten ihr ich
finde schade aber irgendwie ist es ein
zeichen setzen schon mit sicherheit
schwer zu sagen wo man da die grenze
zieht der erste roman des regisseurs
sönke wortmann passt in die zeit es geht
um einen redenschreiber des
außenministers aber nicht nur um politik
und diplomatie
wichtig ist mir auch noch die
streitkultur in deutschland also das was
man sich nicht mehr zuhört dass man
sich nicht ausreden lässt dass man
anderer meinung sollten wir gelten die
stimmung war insgesamt gut auch unter
freiem himmel und für interessierte gibt
es noch einige wenige tickets für morgen
ja nichts sehen aber jetzt erst mal zur
wahl rad-wm da läuft super frist kann
man wohl sagen nach dem mäßigen olympia
auftritt in tokio jetzt ein wahrer
medaillenregen das dritte gold gestern
abend durch sprinterin emma hintze ihre
team kollegin lea sophie friedrich die
holt silber und die gewann heute im 500
meter zeitfahren goldmedaille nummer
vier
schreiber lea-sophie friedrich nach der
erfolgreichen verteidigung ihres
wm-titels ins finale des zeitfahrens
über 500 meter startet die 21 jährige
eigentlich nicht besonders schnell doch
im velodrom von roubaix liegt an
unglaublich kraftvolle endspurt
33,0 57 sekunden bestzeit und bereits
die dritte medaille für lea sophie
friedrich bei dieser wm die russinnen
wunderbar und schnelle war sichern sich
silber und bronze pauline grabosch
verpasst eine medaille als vierter knapp
auf der erfolgsspur von lea-sophie
friedrich fahren lisa brennauer und
franziska brause gleich im finale der
einerverfolgung um gold und silber
zur fußball bundesliga haben die bayern
die tabellenführung durch einen
souveränen heimsieg gegen hoffenheim
verteidigt jede bisherigen ergebnisse
des neunten spieltags
münchen besiegt die tsg mit 14 0 leipzig
gegen führt 4 2 1 wolfsburg kann auch im
achten pflichtspiel hintereinander nicht
gewinnen 0 2 gegen freiburg bielefeld
unterliegt den bayern verfolger dortmund
mit 1 3 das spiel härter gegen gladbach
bereits gestern gewannen 1 gegen
augsburg klar mit 14 1 ja und morgen
dann noch die begegnung in köln
leverkusen stuttgart union und bochum
frankfurt die tabelle bayern also weiter
spitzenreiter mit einem punkt vorsprung
vor dem bvb freiburg überholt leverkusen
und ist jetzt dritter union fünfter
leipzig und mainz klettern auf die
plätze sechs und sieben die zweite
tabellenhälfte die beginnt mit
hoffenheim und am ende alles unverändert
augsburg sechzehnter dahinter bielefeld
und schlusslicht führt
und das abendspiel härter gegen gladbach
ausführlich bei uns im aktuellen
sportstudio um 23 uhr zu gast bei sven
voss der mainzer trainer
svensson
auftaktes ski alpin weltcups in sölden
gewinnt die us amerikanerin michaela
chiffren den riesenslalom 470 sa
weltcupsieg in einem spannenden duell
mit der schweizerin lara gut bahrami
eine straße micaela schäfer in im ziel
ganz oben auf dem podest die erste
weltcup riesenslalom auf dem
rettenbachgletscher von sölden mit zwei
hundertstelsekunden rückstand geht die
amerikanerin in diesem zweiten lauf und
zeigt gerade auf den steilen und
schwierigen passagen dieser strecke eine
glänzende leistung am ende sind es 14
hunderstel vorsprung platz zwei geht an
die schweizerin lara gut behrami dritte
wird die slowakische
gesamtweltcupsiegerin peter wille war
beste deutsche marine schmotz auf rang
ich bin noch nicht ganz bereit
vielen dank
ganz kurz noch zum jäger des verlorenen
schatzes in einer für ihn wohl
ungewohnten rolle harrison ford dreht
gerade auf sizilien einen neuen indiana
jones film und hat dabei selbst einen
schatz verloren seine kreditkarte ein
deutscher tourist fand sie gab sie
zurück und dürfte dabei einen sichtlich
erleichterten indiana jones kennen
lernen ohne gut und peitsche aber dafür
sehr sympathisch erzählt der schwabe
später
morgen können wir uns auf einen sonnigen
herbst sonntag freuen wo sich der nebel
länger hält erzählt gleich katja
honnefer das heute journal mit marietta
slomka um viertel vor elf das gesamte
team der 19 uhr wünscht ihnen einen
fröhlichen samstagabend wir sind morgen
wieder da auf wiedersehen
[Musik]
guten abend am zentralen mittelmeer gibt
es zur zeit kräftige unwetter und das
bleibt auch morgen über tag sodass hoch
quellen burgi yazid nach osten und das
-tief jascha kommt näher zu uns es
bringt aber nur wenig regen mit und
davor wird es recht mild und danach
kommt schon wieder das nächste hoch
heran ein azorenhoch kall bahn sich dann
heute gab es ja ziemlich viele
quellwolken die da über uns hinweg
gezogen sind und die brachten hier und
da auch mal ein paar spritzer regen mit
zum teil aber strahlte die sonne wie zum
beispiel hier im nordwesten oder auch am
alpenrand diese ganzen kleinen
quellwolken werden jetzt in der nacht
mehr oder weniger in sich zusammenfallen
und dann wird es klar es bildet sich
auch mal nehmen oder dunst und nur in
norddeutschland sind die wolkenfelder
etwas dichter die temperaturen sinken in
dieser nacht verbreitet auf +2 bis -3
grad es droht also auch verbreitet
bodenfrost und wenn sie noch
empfindliche pflanzen draußen haben dann
sollten sie jetzt vielleicht reinholen
gleich im anschluss etwas milder bleibt
die nacht an den küsten von nord- und
ostsee und am niederrhein bei 7 bis 5
grad und nach der frostigen nacht bleibt
es auch morgen recht kühl mit 10 bis 16
grad das wird ein sonniger oktober
sonntag allenfalls an der donau oder
bodensee halten sich nebelfelder mal
länger die nebelfelder in
norddeutschland werden auch bis zum
nachmittag weg sein ähnlich startet die
neue woche am dienstag überqueren und
regenwolken die am mittwoch schon wieder
vorbei sind guten abend